[Music]
bozeman montana is with us kyle is on
the line hi kyle welcome to the ramsey
show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm in a bit of a pickle um i'm glad
ken is there because his show's about as
hard to get on as this one so
i have a
opportunity to take another job
right now i'm currently self-employed
but
this other job is in a field that i went
to school for and
and the salary is a little bit less but
there is potential to grow because i'm
starting a new division for this this
company
uh the commercial construction division
that they've done residential for
last 10 years now they want to do
commercial and they've they've kind of
head-hunted me and found me to
start this division for them
i'm just not sure if i should stay
self-employed or take this other job
i think you probably are and i think
your head and heart are probably have a
little bit of a wrestling match
so they are yeah and so what's your head
telling you
uh my head's telling me to take it
because the potential there starting
that the seller will come
but it would just
be a little bit of a blow
initially for the first three three
months i mean 60 to 90 days until we
have a
evaluation
pay evaluation
and we can float that with our savings
the the paid difference sure and but
your heart
what are you making now what would you
be making there
uh by the end of the year this year it'd
be about 110 take home
and and doing that other job um it'd be
84 before taxes
and then what would the bump get you to
after that period that you're saying
that's it that's what kind of i'm unsure
about um whether they could get up to
that 110 to four taxes even um or not so
what i'm trying to understand is why is
your head telling you to take that i
think i know the answer but i want you
to hear yourself say it versus your
heart saying stay and run your company
yes
the potential of of doing that and i've
worked so hard in school to go start
this or to go manage this branch and i i
used to do that do you love what you do
now for yourself
i do um but i'm a trim carpenter so it's
kind of hard on my body and doing that
would be more of a desk job and i could
work from home
80 of the time
yeah but does this any part of this at
home any part of this new job the work
itself when you think about it you run
it through your mind get your heart
pounding like you know being a carpenter
or potentially hiring other carpenters
and you become a true leader of other
carpenters
does does the new job attract your heart
at all be honest
yeah it does i i love that type of work
and when i did it in the past it was it
was great the only reason i left it in
the past was the atmosphere
and this new company the atmosphere is
much different in their uh
christian-based company which which is
big for me and my family so they
and the atmosphere is a lot better so i
think it would turn out a lot better and
i enjoyed the work when i did it
previously okay well so now it sounds
like your heart is more involved and
initially you said it wasn't so i think
this comes down to if you can weather
the financial change
and it really is something and you're
not clear on that so i'd find out i mean
this is not something we're going to
walk into and take that kind of hit with
the hope that it turns into something
you know i i that that'd be my test
there's a tremendous shortage of people
in the construction industry right now
um
i think you just need to go back to them
tell them they need to match your pay
mm-hmm
okay
let me tell you what let me tell you let
me tell you what's stopping you from
doing that
uh this business you're running you're
you i can hear in your voice you're
you're emotionally exhausted
you're tired aren't you
yeah yeah a little bit yeah and a famous
general said fatigue makes cowards of us
all
been there myself my brother i know how
you feel
and so you're not you're not walking in
there with quite the swagger for this
interview that i want you to have
i want you to when you get off the phone
practice walking across the room with
more of a strut
and then call these guys and tell them
you want 110 to start
they're going to give it to you okay
yeah
is that well the initial offer was only
79 yeah and i counted back when then at
90 and then they came down to the 84 so
let me tell you there are things in the
construction world that have almost
doubled in the past eight months
and pay for some things is one of them
i'm building a
event center up here and the dadgum
steel the bill on the steel just came in
and it's just astronomically over budget
it's just gone bananas out there
and
there's a shortage of every industry is
facing labor shortages
every industry is facing them the
construction industry
chief among them
they can't find people to do what they
want you to do
for what they're offering to pay you
kyle i want to ask you something what
would need to be true give me the quick
answer for you to make 50 more
next year or in this next 12 months
owning your own business what would need
to be true for you to make more money
and not have to do all the work yourself
um
i i had to find more contracts which is
kind of a shortage here
i guess um
shortage of work but there's there's
five or six really good trim guys that
have all of the big contracts so all of
the work that i've picked up is one or
two houses a year so it'd be kind of
hard to or wanted to have the people do
one or two houses a year um so there's
no really big
developments that i can get into at the
moment yeah and then and then hiring
somebody and paying the workman's
confidence listen
there's a couple of negotiating
techniques that people use when they're
negotiating price
the mistake people make when they're
negotiating prices the first thing they
do is that he names one price you name
another and we meet in the middle
that usually doesn't work well
instead before you engage in that as
your final step i want you to engage in
i've been thinking about this and i
really appreciate the 84 it's a very
generous offer guys i'm making 110 right
now
tell me the best you can do
this is just not gonna work i i just you
know tell me what you can do and don't
put a number out there just tell them
what you're making now
and just see i'll bet you that one
four-minute conversation makes you ten
grand
i'm just betting you and i'm more
confident in you right now than you are
in you
yeah does it hurt that i already
countered back with 90.
i don't know you're going to figure out
you're gonna have to figure out a way to
couch it so it doesn't feel like you're
um
you know that you're backing out on that
but i think you're taking the job i just
hate for you to take a pay cut because
there's no need in a business that's got
a labor shortage it just doesn't it's
not logical i i got to tell you dave i
wouldn't take it i don't know you don't
think i take it at all i don't think he
takes it his heart's in owning his own
business he's got an opportunity i think
it's the easiest way out right now it's
not the best way out
i'd pass we're hearing different things
yeah okay interesting i'll let the
career guy make the decision